.
IT'S 5:00 AND THAT THIS IS "THE
FIVE."
BEFORE THAT DIDN'T TAKE LONG,
COVID HYPOCRITE NANCY PELOSI
ALREADY BREAKING HER OWN MASK
RULES.
REPUBLICAN LAWMAKERS PROTESTING
THE NEW RULES AFTER A
CAPITOL POLICE MEMO SAID
STAFFERS AND VISITORS COULD BE
ARRESTED FOR NOT COVERING THEIR
FACES.
POLICE ARE BACKING AWAY FROM
THAT ORDER BUT LAWMAKERS COULD
FACE HEFTY CRIMES ATOMIC FINES
AND THEY ARE NOT HAPPY.
>> THEY WILL NOT COMPLY.
NANCY PELOSI HAS OPTED TO RULE
THE SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE MORE A
TYRANT THAN THE SPEED OF THE
HOUSE.
>> NANCY PELOSI IS TOTALLY OFF
THE RAILS.
>> THAT'S WHAT THEY MAKE AND
PEOPLE DON'T WANT TO SEE ANYMORE
IS THIS KIND OF TYRANNICAL
BEHAVIOR OF PEOPLE RUNNING OUR
INSTITUTIONS.
>> Jesse: THAT COMES AS THE
CDC FINALLY RELEASES THE DATA
JUSTIFYING ITS 180 ON MASKS.
DOCUMENTS SAY THE DELTA VARIANT
CAN SPREAD AS EASILY AS A
CHICKEN POX AND VACCINATED
PEOPLE CAN BECOME INFECTED AND
MAY BE ABLE TO SPREAD IT.
BUT THE CDC ALSO SAYS
BREAKTHROUGH CASES ARE STILL
UNCOMMON AND THE DATA IS
PRELIMINARY.
AS "THE NEW YORK POST" POINTS
OUT, OUT OF 169 MILLION
VACCINATED, JUST 1,141 DIED OR
.0007%.
GREG, YOU HAVE MORE LIKELIHOOD
OF DYING IN A CAR CRASH THEN YOU
DO FROM DYING OF COVID IF YOU
ARE VACCINATED.
I DON'T THINK ANYBODY SHOULD
DRIVE ANYMORE.
>> Greg: I DON'T THINK IT'S
EVEN CLOSE.
BUT WHAT THEY ARE SAYING IS YOU
COULD BE ARRESTED.
MEANWHILE YOU COULD'S CHOP LEFT
A $900 WORTH OF STUFF FROM
CALIFORNIA, OVER AND OVER IN
CALIFORNIA AND NOT BE ARRESTED.
IF YOU COULD MUG AND I FELT
PEOPLE IN NEW YORK CITY BUT BE
OUT BEFORE THE PAPERWORK IS
DONE.
BUT YOU CAN GO TO JAIL IF YOU
ARE NOT WEARING A MASK IN D.C.
WHAT DO YOU TELL YOUR CELLMATE?
IT'S NOT VERY IMPRESSIVE WHEN
YOU SAY WHAT ARE YOU IN FOR?
THE STAFFERS COULD BE ARRESTED,
BUT NOT THE ACTUAL HOUSE
MEMBERS.
SO THINK ABOUT THAT, IT'S PURE
POLITICAL PRIVILEGE AND HE
WANTED AN EXAMPLE OF SYSTEMIC
INEQUALITY?
THAT'S IT.
IMAGINE EITHER OF YOU WERE
WEARING MASKS AND YOU ARE NOT
GOING TO WEAR THEM IN THE
OFFICE, THEY SAY WE WILL TAKE
YOU BUT YOU CAN STAY.
OF COURSE YOU WOULD THROW YOUR
STAFF UNDER THE BUS AT ANY
MOMENT.
WE KNOW THIS INEQUALITY EXISTS
IN POLITICS AND IN FACT IT'S THE
MOST COMPELLING REASON TO BECOME
A POLITICIAN, TO BECOME EXEMPT
FROM THE RULES THAT YOU YOURSELF
CREATE.
AND THAT'S WHY GAVIN NEWSOM GETS
A PARTY WITHOUT HIS MASK AND
HUNTER BIDEN GETS TO VIOLATE GUN
LAWS AND YOU CAN DRIVE OFF A
BRIDGE WITH A WOMAN AND SHE
COULD DIE AND YOU COULD STILL
HAVE A POLITICAL CAREER.
THAT'S WHY THEY ARE IN POLITICS,
TO GET AWAY WITH MURDER.
FIGURATIVELY AND LITERALLY.
>> Jesse: RICHARD, YOUR
THOUGHTS?
>> Richard: I AGREE WITH GREG,
YOU COULD NOT RELEASE YOUR TAX
RETURNS AND STILL GO TO JAIL.
>> Greg: BUT YOU KNEW THAT WAS
COMING.
[LAUGHS]
I THINK WE HAVE TO FIGURE OUT
HOW WE GOT HERE.
WE HAVE PEOPLE IN THIS COUNTRY
THAT ARE ON VACCINATED AND
UNVACCINATED PEOPLE ARE
SPREADING THE DELTA VARIANT.
>> Greg: THAT'S NOT TRUE!
>> Richard: WHY ARE WE BACK IN
MASKS THEN?
>> Greg: WE ARE BACK IN MASKS
BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE A PLAN.
>> Richard: DO YOU BELIEVE
THAT COVID-19 IS NOT SPREADING
IN THE CURRENT MOMENT?
AND HOW DO YOU DETERMINE HIS
VACCINATED OR NOT VACCINATED?
>> THE PROBLEM IS YOU CAN'T HAVE
YOUR KICK AND EAT IT TOO?
I DON'T CARE WHAT ANALOGY WANT
TO USE HERE BUT YOU CAN'T SAY WE
DON'T WANT ANY MASKS, WE DON'T
WANT ANY LOCKDOWN BUT WE ARE
ALSO NOT GOING TO TAKE THE
VACCINE.
WE HAVE AN INCREASE IN
HOSPITALIZATIONS AND AN INCREASE
IN DEATH WHICH IS HAPPENING AND
PART OF THE COUNTRY.
>> I WOULD LOVE TO ANSWER SOME
OF RICHARD'S QUESTIONS.
>> I'M NOT TALKING ABOUT -- I'M
TALKING ABOUT ON THE GROUND.
I'VE SEEN YOU OUT THERE.
[LAUGHS]
>> I SEEN YOU.
I HAVE PEOPLE.
[LAUGHS]
>> Kaite: AT THE FIRST REASON
WE HAVE WUHAN CORONAVIRUS IN THE
FIRST PLACE IS BECAUSE OF THE
CHINESE COMMUNIST PARTY AND
PEOPLE LIKE DR. FAUCI TRUST OF
THE WORLD HEALTH ORGANIZATION
EARLY ON.
WE NEVER FOUND OUT WHAT REALLY
HAPPENED AND HAD A HARD TIME
COMBATING THIS FROM THE VERY
BEGINNING.
IN TERMS OF WHY WE ARE NOT
WEARING MASKS NOW IN ACCORDING
TO THE CDC DIRECTOR, SHE SAYS
THAT VACCINATED PEOPLE ARE NOW
INFECTING OTHER VACCINATED
PEOPLE SO THAT'S THE
JUSTIFICATION THAT SHE SAID.
THE MAIN REASON WHY THESE
ADDITIONAL MASK MANDATES AFTER
REVERSING THEM FROM THEIR
DECISION JUST TWO MONTHS AGO.
I THINK WE NEED TO PUMP THE
BRAKES ON THE PANIC HERE.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE DATA OF WHO
IS SUSCEPTIBLE TO DEATH OR
HOSPITALIZATION EVEN WITHOUT THE
VACCINE, IF YOU ARE FROM AGES
18-64, YOU HAVE 99.5% OF
SURVIVING COVID-19 WITHOUT THE
VACCINE.
IF YOU ARE OVER 65 YOUR RISK
GOES UP OR DEATH OR
HOSPITALIZATION.
IN TERMS OF THE NEW VARIANT FOR
DELTA, THE MEDIA IS PANICKING
AND RECKLESSLY REPORTING IT AS
THERE ARE MORE CASES AND MORE
HOSPITALIZATIONS.
AT THE HOSPITALIZED ARE ON
VACCINATED AND THE BREAKTHROUGH
CASES ARE NOT SERIOUS ILLNESS.
SO THE STANDARD HAS MOVED TO,
CASES ARE, PEOPLE ARE JUST
GETTING SICK RATHER THAN HAVING
A SERIOUS ILLNESS AND CREATING
PANIC OUT OF IT BECAUSE IT'S
GOOD FOR THE MEDIA.
AND THE CDC HAS BEEN TERRIBLE ON
THE MESSAGES.
IF YOU WANT TO KNOW WHY WE ARE
BACK HERE IT'S BECAUSE THE
STANDARDS HAVE MOVED AND THEY
ARE TREATING PEOPLE IN A WAY
THAT DOES NOT HAVE CIVIL
LIBERTIES.
THE >> Shannon: IF YOU LOOK AT
THE CDC SLIDE PRESENTATIONS AND
THEY ARE TALKING ABOUT THE FACT
THAT --
>> Greg: SHANNON, WE HAVE TO
CUT YOU OFF BECAUSE NO ONE CAN
HEAR YOU APPARENTLY.
>> Shannon: OH, I LOVE THIS,
THIS IS SO COZY.
ANYWAY.
LISTEN.
THE CDC IS NOW GOING TO HAVE TO
MOVE THE GOALPOST IN FULL VIEW
OF THE PUBLIC AS
"WASHINGTON POST" SAID LAST
NIGHT BECAUSE WE ARE GETTING
MORE DATA BUT IF THE DATA IS
RELYING ON A STUDY OUT OF INDIA
PARTIALLY THAT DEALS WITH
VACCINES THAT WE DON'T -- OH, I
THINK I HAVE MY MICROPHONE NOW.
[LAUGHS]
>> WE ARE NOT SOCIAL DELETE
DISTANCE.
BUT THE CDC HAS COMPUTERS SO
MANY PEOPLE SO EVEN WHEN YOU
HAVE MAINSTREAM MEDIA SAYING IT
SO CONFUSING, THEY HAD A TOTAL
MELTDOWN IN D.C. WHERE MANY OF
US AT THIS TABLE LIVE AND WORK
AND EAT AND DO ALL THOSE KINDS
OF THINGS SAYING, THE MAYOR SAID
THE CITY IS OPEN BUT EVERYBODY
HAS TO RE-MASK.
THEIR BUSINESSES ARE NOW
COMPLAINING SAYING WE HAVE HELD
ON FOR 15 OR 16 MONTHS.
THIS IS SO CONFUSING, PEOPLE
AREN'T GOING TO COME OUT AGAIN
BECAUSE THEY ARE AFRAID AND THEY
THINK THEY CAN'T GET IN WITHOUT
A MASK AND WE DON'T KNOW WHAT TO
DO AND YOU ARE HURTING OUR
ABILITY TO REOPEN.
>> I UNDERSTAND THAT, I THINK
THE CDC MESSAGE HAS BEEN VERY
CONFUSING.
BUT THAT DOESN'T TAKE AWAY FROM
THE FACT THAT HOSPITALIZATION
RATES ARE BACK TO WHERE WE WERE
IN JANUARY, BACK TO MID-MAY AND
APRIL ACCORDING TO BLOOMBERG.
SO IN PLACES LIKE FLORIDA,
MID-MARCH AND EARLY APRIL, BUT
STILL MORE PEOPLE THAN WE WERE.
>> IN THE LAST TWO WEEKS THERE
WAS ONE PERSON WHO DIED FROM
COVID.
>> Jesse: WE AVERAGE ONE DEATH
PER WEEK IN D.C.
>> BUT THOSE ARE DIFFERENT
REGIONS.
AND I AGREE WITH YOU.
>> Shannon: AND WE'VE HAD 11
HOMICIDES AT VICTIMS